Nga pikpamja arkitektonike kjë salë ështi dheuar më ulët dhe më ngushës.
Pranija e prangave dhe hejkurave dëshmon prani në invazjonit të huajë.
Osmanët deprëtuan në Evropë në funë të shekulit 14, në vitin 1371 në Marica,
dhe në vitin 1380 në në Savër të Lushnjes.
Në vitin 1389 ushvillua beteja e fuëshë Kosovës,
në radët e koalicjonit anti-Osmanë u daluan shqiptardhë.
Në këtë betei, shqiptari nga Kosovëa, Miloš Kopili, arritit e vras Sultan Muratin e parë,
këruja upushtuan nga Turcid në vitin 1450.
Në këtë salë paraqiten.
Harfëta e invazjonit Osmanë.
Kushtrimi e arbryd mozaik.
Odgjaku i Kastriotëve.
Špata dhuruar Ferdinandit të Napolit riprodhim.
Gjergj Kastrioti ishte djali mëj vogelj i Gjon Kastriotiëtë prijsi të Principates.
Zotërimete para të ti ishënë dëv shatra në Dibër, Sinja dhe Gardhi i Poštem.
Gjon Kastrioti pasira në vasalitetin e Sultan Muratit II, u detrua ti apati 54 djemë,
dër ta edhe Gjergin të cilin Osmanëtë e prgatitën në školen e i Koglanve.
Osmanët idhan emrin në nëshender, që korrespondon me emrin e Krishtër Alexander.
Me pas ataj idhan edhe gradën ështarake Beg e për këtar su e Aynjetës iskender Beg.